spaced repetition systems, SRS, Anki.
Most language learning systems, including
LingQ, do incorporate some form of spaced
repetition into their program of learning.
It's a tool to enable people
to remember words primarily.
Although SRSs can be used in
science, can be used in other fields.
Even in language, it can be used
to try to remember phrases and words.
The whole idea is that with a system of
spaced repetition, and specifically an
expanding space, in other words, there is
an algorithm which someone or different
people have different algorithms, which
say that if you space the repetition out
initially, let's say two days, 10 days,
30 days, 50 days, whatever it might be,
that this is going to improve your ability
to retain the items that you're learning.
So, I have not been a great practitioner
of spaced repetition systems or a user
of these spaced repetition systems.
I did, however, use a form of
space repetition when I was
learning Chinese characters a
long, long time ago, 50 years ago.
I
had a box here of these lovely
hand drawn Chinese characters, and
there's a thousand of them here, and I
went through all one thousand characters
with these squared Chinese textbooks.
And I would write one character,
let's say 10, 15 times,
and then a couple of columns over.
I would put either the sound, the
pronunciation, or the meaning.
Then I'd pick up another character
or another flashcard, and I would
continue doing that, write it 10 times.
Eventually I ran into the first
card and I'd have to remember
it before I had forgotten it,
and I would keep on doing that.
I started out with 10 a day.
I got it up to 30 a day.
Of course,
forgetting a lot, relearning.
And I did that for a thousand characters.
Thereafter, to learn the remaining
3,000 characters that I had to learn,
I just relied on coming across them in
my reading, writing them out a few times.
So that's my experience
with space repetition.
Of course, that was not an algorithm.
It was not an expanding space,
spaced repetition system.
It was just some form of spacing.
Now, doing some research on the subject,
I discovered that while there are
studies that show that some kind
of expanding spaced repetition is
beneficial to learning, there are
other studies that show that it is the
repetition that's beneficial to learning.
That even if you have constant spacing,
there is no significant difference.
And I will leave some links here in the,
uh, description box so that you can go
and check these different people out.
So it's not obvious that all of
the research confirms that what we
consider to be space repetition,
this expanding spacing is all
that beneficial for learning.
Now the next thing is applying
this to language learning. Because
it's one thing if we're learning,
you know, facts, scientific facts, even
historical data. Or even in the case of my
Chinese characters, while these characters
were being learned sort of away from any
context, at least, there is a significant
connection between the characters
because there's a lot of repetition
of elements in these characters.
So that I was learning and getting
a greater and a better sense of how
these different elements combined
in these characters that I was
learning when we're learning words.
There still are some
elements or components.
But it's not as clear as was the case
when I was learning Chinese characters.
So when we learn a language, of course
we're concerned about input, we're
concerned about comprehension, and we are
concerned about producing the language.
And so we need, obviously, we need
words in order to understand the
language and eventually to produce it.
And as you know, I'm a big
proponent of inputb-based learning,
getting the language in you.
Getting words in you so that
you understand the language
and eventually can use it.
So in studying how the brain learns, there
is a thing called "Event-Related Potential,"
which measures how the brain deals
with sentences that it hears or reads.
So the brain tends to predict what's
going to happen in this sentence or
phrase or whatever. And it basically has
certain predictions in terms of the
meanings, sort of the semantics if
you want, and in terms of the syntax.
In other words, how the structure should
work based on its familiarity with the
language, its exposure to the language.
It makes certain assumptions.
And in this way, researchers are able to
tell what is important for the brain
to be able to understand that sentence.
Well, it turns out that while frequency
of exposure is extremely important,
lexical frequency, in other words,
how often they've seen the word.
However, as the learner has more and
more exposure to a variety of contexts,
the lexical frequency, in other words,
frequency as a factor becomes much
less important than previous exposure
to a variety of different contexts.
And in the description, they talk
about the lexical frequency being
sort of a bottoms up, bits and pieces
approach to how the learner reacts
to words and phrases in a sentence.
Whereas over time, with enough
exposure to the language, it's more
of a top down form of reaction that
dominates our ability to understand
and eventually to predict what's going to
happen in the sense or to react if
what happened in the sentence didn't
correspond to what our brain expected.
But it's the buildup of that familiarity
with the context, what to expect,
which is more important than the
frequency of exposure to the words.
So that is important.
Bear in mind that, as I said when
I was talking about Spitzer's
book, learning takes place when
we have frequency of exposure.
When there is similarity. Obviously,
if I'm going to study, say on LingQ,
Finish, as opposed to Dutch,
I'm going to have an easier time with Dutch
because it's more similar to what I know.
Also in that similarity, I think
there's also included in that
some sense of association with
similar things, related things.
All of this contributes to whether or
not we're going to get the neurons firing,
whether the synapse is going to take place.
But the other thing, the third thing,
was relevance or importance, which
is also an important consideration
in determining whether the brain is
going to choose to learn this thing.
If
it considers it to be,
you know, important.
It's important to bear these things
in mind when we consider how a
space repetition system works.
Obviously, if we take the position that
exposure to a lot of content and a lot
of context reduces the importance of the
frequency of exposure to the word itself,
that's a consideration.
And if our approach to comprehension
is very much tied up with context
and relating words to other words
in context that we have seen before,
structures that we have seen before,
it reduces the specific importance
of just the frequency of exposure to
the word, which is kind of what spaced
repetition system tends to stress.
That's insofar as
comprehension is concerned.
Now let's look at production.
The interesting thing about production
is that planning and memory are
located in the same parts of our brain.
Because to plan something, you have
to be able to remember something that
you want to plan to do in the future.
And when we produce a language,
apparently, and I, again, I'll leave
a link to this in the description box,
there's a lot of planning involved.
What are we going to say?
How are we going to structure it?
Which words are we going to use?
And the planning involves a process of,
first of all, using the
easily retrieved words first.
Because that gets you going.
Reusing patterns that have worked for you
before and suppressing those things that
might seem similar but aren't relevant.
A word that sounds almost the same
or is spelled almost the same. Or
interference from another language.
We have to suppress those.
So the brain has sort of a three-part
process, finding the easily
retrieved words and phrases to use,
reusing things that worked before.
And suppressing those
things that they don't want.
But all of this requires
a significant memory.
And if that memory is best achieved
through massive exposure to the
language rather than isolated
review of words, maybe that's
where we should orient ourselves.
If we look at spaced repetition systems
per se, it seems that in the case
of language, language learners might
have, depending on where they are in
the language, 500 words in their deck.
5,000 words in their deck. A large number
of words potentially in their deck.
Now, language learning is a function of
attitude, of time, and of the ability
to focus on what it is you're doing.
So obviously, if you like doing
spaced repetition, if you like doing
flashcards, it's something you should do.
The research that I did (I went to
ChatGPT) suggested that the average
person spends 30 seconds on a flashcard.
I can't imagine spending
30 seconds on a flashcard.
I do, and I'll explain a little
later how I use flashcards, but
in my case, it's a few seconds.
It's not 30 seconds.
It's just exposure.
But I guess people who are trying
to remember that flashcard might
spend 30 seconds on a flashcard.
At least that's what ChatGPT told me.
So if we look at word frequency,
as I've said before, word frequency
declines very, very quickly.
So in the most frequent words,
obviously just in any content,
any context, you are going to get
exposed to the very frequent words.
The bigger issue is if we look at word
frequency, and I'll show you a list
here and you'll see that words that
are in the 50th spot in terms of word
Frequency, or 500th spot or 5000th spot,
may only appear once or twice in a book.
In other words, these statistics
were based on Google's corpora of
content, but some of these words,
even fairly common words, like, you
know, "road" or I don't know, whatever,
they may not appear that often.
How are you going to learn them?
Obviously, you can guide the process.
If you're reading "Harry Potter" the word
"Harry" is going to appear a lot of times.
I've never read "Harry Potter" but words
having to do with magicians and so
forth are going to be there more often.
If you're talking about economics or
history, there are certain relatively
rare words that will appear more
often. But nevertheless, you are
chasing a very small number or
a low frequency of occurrence.
Of these words that you nevertheless
require, because on any given page,
there's going to be 10 of these low-frequency
words. And not understanding
them is going to limit your ability
to understand what's on the page.
So then perhaps that's a place
to use spaced repetition systems,
because you can then go after words
that won't appear naturally often
enough for you to learn them.
But with spaced repetition,
you can then zoom in on them.
The problem is, and this is the dilemma,
if there are potentially 10-, 20,000 words
that you need to learn, if you actually
do them in spaced repetition systems,
you will end up spending almost all
your time on these flashcard reviews.
Obviously, if you have seven or eight
hours a day to spend learning the
language, then that might be where you
choose to spend your time. And let me
stress, it's entirely a matter of personal
choice. So I would not choose to do that.
In fact, I don't choose to do that.
But people who enjoy doing that, then
that's what they should do.
I find that when I'm reviewing
flashcards, if it's divorced from any
context, then I quickly lose interest.
So I find it hard to focus.
So once you're not focusing, once
you no longer consider it relevant,
important, then I can't continue.
So I occasionally do go through
lists at LingQ, especially of
my Status 3 words.
Trying to move them to
known because I have a goal.
I want to increase my Known Words total,
but still I can only do it for so long.
10, 15 minutes max.
It's all about sort of "bits and pieces
learning" versus "top down learning."
When we're dealing with flashcards,
when we're reviewing grammar rules, we
are dealing with the bits and pieces.
When we are just reading and
listening, we're in the sort of
"top down learning mode," and I
prefer to spend most of my time
in a "top down learning mode."
But there is sort of a compromise,
which I now really enjoy doing.
In the case of my Persian, given where
I am, call it a [CEFR] B1 level in Persian,
still struggling with a writing system
that's still not very familiar to me.
I enjoy going into Sentence Review.
The content that I'm using is timestamped.
I can listen to it.
I can go through it, look at the
words that are still not known to me.
I'm still dealing with content that I've
read before, so there are no more sort
of unknown words, but there's a lot of
yellow words that I still don't yet know.
If I want to, I can go into any one
of these sentences and go through the
matching pairs flashcards exercise.
I can go through the exercise
of reconstituting the sentence.
That's really sort of drilling down
into "bits and pieces learning,"
which, of course, slows me down.
So I don't do a lot of it.
I do it on a sampling basis because I
think it helps give me a better sense
of the structure of the language.
It just increases, at some level, my
familiarity with the language, even
though it's slows down my taking in
as much of the language as possible.
And I think the lesson here, or the
message that I would like to end
with, is in language learning, of
course, our attitude is important.
The amount of time we spend, and remaining
focused so that we pay attention to
what's happening in the language.
So therefore, we need to
do what we like doing.
We need to do what we're going to
happily spend time doing, and we
need to do things that we think
are important so we remain focused.
And so I don't think any
one system, you know, you should
do this or you should do that.
You should use SRS,
should not use SRS.
I don't think that's good advice.
We never really know when we're
engaged in some language learning
activity, how effective that activity
is compared to some other activity.
We know that as long as we are engaged
with the language in some way, we are
learning. Now, are we learning less well
than if we were doing something else?
Are we learning faster than if
we were doing something else?
It's very hard to tell if we have
a sense that we're improving.
If we have a sense that we are
enjoying the process, then we should
continue doing what we're doing.